beckham a publié une photo de lui et sa
fille de 7 ans alors hier sur instagram
et ça fait polémique partout parce qu'il
embrasse sur la bouche c'est une
question qu'on s'est tous posé au bureau
que je vous posais justement parce que
ce geste a suscité beaucoup de réactions
dans les commentaires
certains sont indignés d'autres l'ont
défendu on vous afin de tirer 4 et
j'aimerais bien avoir votre avis
là-dessus
moi j'ai lu beaucoup de livres
concernant la plus fondamentale à
françoise dolto
allez on regarde
[Musique]
c'est une photo qui crée la polémique
depuis deux jours sur les réseaux
sociaux
un cliché posté lundi par le footballeur
international david beckham avec sa
fille harper âgé de 7 ans et ce qui fait
parler c'est que le sportif embrasse sa
fille sur la bouche le mannequin avait
déjà fait face à une polémique similaire
en 2017 et s'était expliqué à l'époque
j'ai été élevé comme ça et c'est comme
ça qu'on est avec les enfants victoria
et moi on veut montrer à nos enfants
notre amour et on les protège
on veille sur eux on les soutient
pourtant certains internautes trouve ce
comportement inapproprié et de nombreux
spécialistes de la petite enfance sont
d'accord si certains trouvent ce
comportement choquant en publiant une
nouvelle photo un an après la première
polémique le footballeur semble vouloir
montrer qu'il fait ce qu'il veut et
qu'il assume sans complexe l'éducation
qu'ils dispensent as safir
non est-ce que qu'est-ce qui est choqué
par ce geste et dites-nous chez vous je
vous demande hs que vous êtes choqué par
le geste de david beckham ou pas au
bureau je vous jure ce matin quand on a
préparé l'émission parce que c'est vrai
qu'on vous n'y êtes pas eh bien on était
il y en avait beaucoup qui étaient
choqués vous mais maintenant je suis pas
choquée elle est encore tout petit alors
après il faudrait qu'il faut définir de
toute façon effectivement un âge un âge
où c'est fini on ne peut plus à 42 ans
sont enfin moi c'est vrai que en général
c'est où le père ou la mère va voir si
votre fils j'ai embrassé mon fils sur la
boule quand il était petit jusqu'aux
alentours de 5 ans à peu près à passer
et ils sont pas pas au bout d'un moment
on m'a dit on arrête
il faut une tierce personne alors en
règle générale la maman avec le garçon
passé le père qui joue ce rôle là et
puis l inverse
voilà mais je vois là pour l'instant
elle est encore un joli petit loft a dû
être vous choquer mais moi j'en vois ce
encore ma mère sur la bouche
votre mère sur la brèche nous dans notre
famille on est un peu de d'origine de
l'est et ses traditions s'embrasse sur
la bouche en main sur la bouche
william accambray sur la bouche mes
enfants non mais en référé a même son
nom que tu as à gaz il m'a dit et le
dimanche ça va tous en train de
s'embrasser santé amène le gigot sans
moi non mais chez des sables c'est comme
ça on s'en va sur la crise et boba web
apps et s'adresse bien moi ça me
rapproche un smack
c'est pas grand chose moi moi je moi je
fais franchement je peux pas faire un
smack à quelqu'un et c'est vrai qu'à
plein de gens qui disent ça va embrasser
sur la bouche c'est voilà c'est ça ça
passe quoi ça passe oui on se passerait
là vraiment c'est un jeune artiste de
calèche sauvage et est annoncé je ne les
gêne mais je les traite m'embrasser ni
sur la bouche mission dresse à brive où
le couple en restant correct on a besoin
mais que cela n'était pas du tout une
bise rieuse des tests savons pas non
plus qu'on membres a été bidouillé oui
je déteste bisouiller sera tactile
d'accord j'étais un peu du team derrière
cette équipe donc je pète activement
crois que c'est l'interview
nota les couches et faustine bollaert 1
raconte ça y est je pense que c'est un
petit bisou ça pourrait me choquer c'est
vraiment ils ont roulé une pelle à merde
j'ai perdu là
[Musique]
ça me dérange isabelle vous est une
hérésie télévisuelle vous pouvez pas
dire ça c'est impossible les autres
aussi vous rendez pas compte
tolérer ça ce que ça veut dire à la
limite qu'il le fasse mais qu'il publie
un cliché c'est une honte
il ya plein de gens qui vont voir ça
qu'ils vont voir un homme certes c'est
son père mais on oublie ça sur les
réseaux sociaux
il faut voir un homme âgé embrasse un
mot moi je vous le dis vous dites que
des gens étaient choqués au bureau ben
moi j'ai été extrêmement choqué quand
j'ai vu ce cliché je comprends parce que
parce que c'est dans une salle de
rangement et ben moi ça me dérange parce
que c'est et je trouve que vous êtes
extrêmement à du genre ici parce que ça
peut être très dérangeant je suis désolé
au jour d'aujourd'hui les images comme
ça elles peuvent véhiculer des idées
pour clermont france est certes un
pervers même si même si c'est un enfant
mais je mens je suis choquée m'arrêter
franchement cela la vraie le film moon
est choqué aussi à moi je suis pas du
tout pour les bisous comme ça mes
parents m'ont n'ont jamais fait mais
heureusement maintenant c'est dans
certaines familles c'est la mode et
enfin et la culture c'est une chose mais
par exemple moi j'avais j'avais oncles
ou tantes comme ça et eux c'était la
culture de faire comme ça chez leurs
enfants et donc nous aussi quand on se
faisait garder tous et moi j'ai le
souvenir du bisou et après de faire
comme ça j'ai bossé ses deux enfants
moi j'aime aller